The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
SE BAEK OH: Good morning.
My name's Se Baek, and
I'm a postdoc working
with Professor Barbastathis.
And he has a personal emergency
today, so he couldn't make it.
So actually Pepe and I
will give a lecture today.
And just for a reminder, you
can turn in your first homework
today before class
or after class.
OK, so yesterday, we talk about
a bunch of different things.
The first one we derived--
by the way, excuse
me, we are going
to do the same
thing, same format.
So if you have any
questions, just feel free
to interrupt and
ask questions, OK?
So the last time,
we actually derived
the ray transfer matrix
for a thin lens, which
is the spherical lens has
two curvatures, the first one
and second one, which is here,
the 1 and negative 1 over f. f
is focal length and 1, 0.
And the focal length
1 over f, this
actually we derived
this equation,
the [INAUDIBLE] equation.
So if you know the reflective
index and the radius curvature,
the left side and
right side, then you
can just easily compute the
focal length of your thin lens.
Then, also, we talked about
the object at infinity
and the image at infinity.
So for example, in this case,
we have the object at infinity.
So we have this ray is
coming from the infinity.
And we are going to have the
focus point at the focal plane.
That's the definition of the
focal length and focal plane.
And the other way, if we had
the point object at focal plane,
then we are going to have
an image at infinity.
So that's the same thing.
And if you have the
negative length, I mean,
the focal length is negative,
then we have the same thing.
We have parallel coming in.
In this case, it bent outside.
But if you extract
and extend, then we
have the focal point here.
So as you know the object
and image they are conjugate.
And in this case, [INAUDIBLE]
object or image is at infinity.
So we call it, I mean
this configuration,
as infinite conjugate.
[INAUDIBLE], please.
Yeah.
Because, you know, one
of them is at infinity.
So yeah, that's what we
talked about yesterday.
And today, we're
going to be talking
about interesting topic.
So what if we have our object or
an image is at finite distance?
It's more realistic case.
Just like when you take
a picture of your person,
I mean, of a friend,
then your friend is not
going to be at infinity, right?
So it's more realistic case.
And then we'll talk
about thick lens.
Because so far, we just assume
our lens is infinitely thin.
So thick lens is more
like the realistic case.
And then the paper we'll talk
about is human visual system.
So I guess this
slide is probably
one of the most important
slides of this whole course.
Because, you know, we are
dealing with the object
and image at finite distance.
So the situation is like this.
We have a lens with focal
length F. And in object space,
we are given our object
as some distance.
You know, the
situation's like this.
You have a camera.
And you take a
picture of a person.
Then where should I put
my screen or detector?
Or in the other
way around, there
must be some condition that
makes the perfect image, right?
So if you take a picture
at some distance,
then the other object which
is not at that distance
will look blurry in
your final image, right?
So we are going to find what
condition should be satisfied
here in terms of the distance
in object space and focal length
and distancing image space.
And we're going to see what
kind of image we will get
or how big it is, OK?
So the first one
is, what is image.
So what it image?
So image is just replicate
of an object, right?
So in terms of this
ray picture, we
have infinite number of rays--
oh, sorry-- emanating
from the object point.
And if this configuration is
an image configuration, which
means you make a perfect image,
then all these rays, at least
most of them, they
should be converge
at a point in object
space somewhere, right?
So that's the image in question.
You have bunch of ray
coming from this point,
and they should
meet at one point.
So you can draw many, many
ways, but of your choice
is just two rays here, this
first ray and the second way.
And since every ray should meet
at one point in image space,
these two ways also should
meet at the same point.
And the reason why we chose only
two rays is kind of obvious,
because we know the infinite
conjugate configuration, right?
So the first ray, the
upper ray here, this ray,
it looks like coming from the
object at infinity, right?
It's parallel to
the optical axis.
So after the lens, it should
pass the focal point like this.
And we call this point
as back focal plane,
since it is behind the lens.
And what about the
second ray here?
So if you choose, that ray is
passing through the focal point
which is in front of the lens,
we call the front focal plane,
then at the lens it looks like
coming from the focal point,
right?
So it should be going
to the infinity.
So it's collimated and
parallel to the optical axis.
And these two rays
meet at this point.
So that point is where
you get the image.
And the other rays, the
infinite number rays,
should meet at that point.
So this is how we draw
the configuration image.
So we have bunch of ray and
bunch of ray in image space.
Any questions so far?
OK.
So to find the relation between
the object distance and image
distance, let's define
two distance here.
So first one is x0, the
distance from the object
to the front focal plane.
And this second one is xi,
so from that focal point
to the image.
So we are going to see how
they relate to the focal length
here.
So first thing is we can compare
it to a big triangle here.
So the first one is--
oops-- this triangle
OPFf and this one, BCFf.
Since they are similar, so
if you see this height of PO
and this BC is same as h--
actually, they are h object
over xo, so ho and xo.
And it should be
same as negative h i.
The negative sign is
because h i is negative.
So to make the
positive, you have
to put the negative sign here.
And this [INAUDIBLE], right?
So you get this first relation.
And you can compare
the other triangles
at image space, so this
ACFb and IQF, this one.
So if you do the same thing,
then we have this relation.
So QI, which is the image
height, and FPQ, this is xi.
And we have the h, the object
height, over focal length.
So we have this relation
and the second relation.
So if you combine them, we have
two interesting equation here.
The first one is h,
the image of height,
over x, or the object height, is
xi over h or equal to negative
f over xo.
And it's also same as
negative xi over f.
Can anyone guess
what this quantity
means, So h i over ho, so
image height or object height?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
SE BAEK OH: Right, exactly.
SE BAEK OH: Yeah, for
he said magnification.
Yeah.
Course, you know,
this is a ratio
of the size of the
image and object.
So actually, this term
indicate the magnification
of your imaging system, right?
So magnification actually
is defined by this, just h i
over ho.
If the absolute value of
magnification is larger than 1,
then you're going to
get the magnified image.
Course, the image height is
bigger than object height,
right?
And if it is smaller
than 1, we are
going to get the
smaller image, right?
And if you combine the
rest, these two equations,
so f over x and
xo and xi over f,
then you can get this equation.
xo times xi should be f squared.
So xo is this distance, so
object to the focal plane,
the front focal plane.
And xi is from that focal
point to the image plane.
So this tells you where
should you put the detector
or object to make an
image condition, right?
So they are related like this.
So this is one of the form
of the imaging condition.
And we it Newton's form, OK?
And sometimes it is more
convenient to define
the distance from object to
the lens, not the focal plane.
So we define two other
distance, so s o, object
distant from object to the
lens, and image distance, si,
from lens to image.
And actually in this
picture in this figure,
we can draw another way, which
is from object to the image.
But it passed through
the center of the lens,
and it looks like just a path
straight through the lens.
And can anyone guess why?
Because at the center of the
lens, at the very center,
the radius curvature is
kind of infinite, right?
So it just looks like
just piece of flat glass.
So if you have this
piece of glass,
then you know from
the [INAUDIBLE] law
the incident ray and
the outgoing ray,
they are parallel, right, if
you have the same median here
and here.
And also, we are talking
about the very thin lens here.
So we don't really consider
the thickness of the lens.
So that's why it looks
like just passing straight
through the lens.
So you can draw actually
three rays here, so
the first one, this one,
and this one, and this one.
And then you can
compare two, actually,
another big triangles, so OCA
this one, and IQC, this one.
So if you compare that triangle,
then we're going to get--
so CA over CB, so CA
[INAUDIBLE] CB, which
is the, actually, magnification
here, ho over negative h i
should be same as this object
distance and image distance.
So this tells you, if you have
the object distance and image
distance, they are related
to the magnification.
So if your object is very
far away from the lens,
then you're going to get
very small image, right?
Because you have [INAUDIBLE].
So you have the
very big one here,
so you're going to
get a small one.
But if you move your
object to the lens,
then there are big change.
You're going to get the
magnified one, magnified image.
And if you combine this
equation and this relation
and these two, then we are
going to have the si over s o.
And it's the same as f over xo.
So xo is actually s o minus
f, right, so s o minus f.
Yeah, let me do the
[INAUDIBLE],, please.
So let me rewrite that equation.
I just flip the numerator
and denominator.
So s o over si is same
as s o minus f and f.
And it should be
same as s o over f.
And it's minus 1, right?
And I divide by s o here.
So I get 1 over si
should be 1 over f--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
s i or [INAUDIBLE] s o,
or so over [INAUDIBLE]?
SE BAEK OH: No, I just flipped
the numerator, denominator.
So it was si over s o,
but I wrote s o over si.
So this one also flips,
right, s o minus f over f.
And I end up with 1 over si
equal to 1 over f minus 1
over s o, which is
the final equation.
So we call this the lens law.
So 1 over object distance
versus 1 over image distance
should be 1 over f.
So, yeah.
So actually, that's the
equation in most of time
we are going to use.
OK, so we just
finished probably one
of the most important slides.
Any questions?
So by using this
equation, we can
analyze different situation.
So let's first see the four
different situation here.
We have positive lens
and negative lens.
And the upper left situation
is what we just described.
So the object distance is
longer than front focal length.
So you draw the two rays,
the upper one and right one.
And you just trace them,
and they meet at one point.
And you're going
to get the image.
And we call this
one as real image,
because all this ray MRI
is departing at that point.
They actually meet
at this point.
So if you put a
screen there, then you
can actually see those
image of the object.
So that's why we
call the real image.
And it's inverted, right?
Because it was going up right.
It's down right.
And magnification
is definitely small.
It's negative, because inverted.
And also, if you see the
distance, object distance,
this one and this one,
then you can easily
see you're going to have--
actually, it depends on the
object distance, but yeah.
And in terms of
equation, so this s o
is bigger than
focal length, right?
So this 1 over s o is actually
smaller than 1 over f.
So si should be positive.
You need to add
something, right?
Because this one is
smaller than this one.
So that's why we
have the si, which
is positive distance here.
But if you think
about this situation,
so object distance now is
smaller than focal length.
It's closer than the
front focal plane.
Then you can still
draw these two rays.
One is parallel to
the optical axis.
And the other one is passing
through the front focal plane.
But after the
lens, actually they
don't meet, because
they are diverging.
So if you back trace,
then they actually
meet in front of the lens.
So we call this as
a virtual image,
because it looks like
coming from that point.
But if you put a
screen there, the--
just a second.
So [INAUDIBLE],, I'm not using
the [INAUDIBLE] right now.
So OK, thanks.
So if you put the screen
there, then you don't really
see the actual image.
It just looks like these
two rays behind the lens,
they look coming
from this point.
So that's the definition
of the virtual image.
And as you can see here,
we have the erect image.
And it's bigger than
the original object,
which is green.
So magnification
is bigger than 1.
In terms of the equation, so
now s o is smaller than f.
So 1 over s o is actually
bigger than 1 over f, right?
So actually this guy
should be negative,
which means si also
which indicate your image
distance is negative.
So you are going to have the
image in front of your lens,
right?
And the negative lens, we have
the negative focal length here.
So that's why the front
focal plane is actually
behind the lens, not
in front of the lens.
So you can still draw these
two rays, but they don't meet.
They make a virtual image
in front of the lens.
And we have the virtual and
erect image and magnification.
We get actually
the smaller image.
And if you do the
same thing here,
we are going to get
the virtual, erect.
And it's also smaller image.
OK, so, so far, we just
talk about the thin lens
and how they make the image--
sorry, Pepe will pass
around the convex lens,
which was the upper case.
So if you move your
screen or eyes,
then you can see actually it
was inverted, but it's erect.
So you have to see the
flipped image, right?
So he's going to pass around.
GUEST SPEAKER: So one way to
do it is just look at the lens,
look at your notebook.
And you can have it just
at the right distance,
the image would look
inverted and floating
on top of the lens,
which is the real image.
And if you put it closer,
which means that now we
have the second case
there, the image
will be erect, so
not inverted anymore,
and would look behind
the lens, right?
So it's actually pretty
dramatic, the change.
SE BAEK OH: Yeah.
Actually, the upper right
configuration is the exact same
from as magnifier.
So you know, magnifier
that detective are using?
Yeah, So the next question is,
what if we have multiple lenses
like this, this case?
So here we have two lenses.
Each one has a
focal length of 10.
So let's say unit
is a millimeter.
So the focal length, is just
10 millimeter, 10 millimeter.
And the gap between the
lens is 5 millimeter.
And we are given
an object, which
is the distance from the object
to the first lens is just 5
millimeter.
And we want to find what
kind of image we get
and where it is at
somewhere around here.
So can anyone
guess how to do it?
Because we just talk
about a single lens,
but what if we have
the multiple lens?
No one?
So actually the answer is
pretty straightforward.
So you just cascade, which
means your first [INAUDIBLE]
the first lens.
So you just find the
image of the object
through the first lens.
And that image becomes the
object to the second lens.
And do the same thing
to find the image.
And if you have
more lens, you just
repeat the same process, OK?
So let's first try it.
So here I just neglect
the second lens.
I only have the first lens,
which has the object distance 5
millimeter.
And the focal length is 10.
So I can draw the two or
three rays to find the image.
But to be precise, I
just plug into equation.
So 1 over 5, which
is this distance,
the 5 is this distance.
We want to find
the image distance.
If it is positive, then we
are going to get real image.
But if it is negative,
then we are going
to get the virtual image here.
And it should be
1 over 10, which
is the focal length, right?
And it turns out that this s
prime, this image distance, is
actually negative
10, which means
we have the negative image,
which is in front of the lens.
This distance is 10 millimeter.
And if you compare the
magnification, which
is defined by the object
distance and image distance,
so it's negative, there
is a negative side.
So negative, negative, negative
10 over 5 is actually 2.
So we have a erect
virtual image which
is twice larger
than original image.
This is the first lens.
And this image is now an
object to the second lens.
So we had the
virtual image here,
which was the 10 millimeter
in front of the lens.
But if you only think
about second lens,
then this object distance
should be 15 millimeter, right?
So if you do the same thing.
so now we have the 1 over
15 from here to here.
And we want to find
the image distance.
1 over s prime
should be 1 over 10,
which is just positive
30 millimeter.
So after 30 millimeter, we are
going to have the real image.
And if you compare
the magnification
of the second lens, then
it's negative 30 over 15.
So we have the negative 2.
So we have the real image
here, which is inverted one.
And that is twice larger
than this virtual--
I mean, the object
of the second image.
Because, actually, we initially
had two lens like this.
So the overall magnification
is just multiplication
of individual magnification.
So first one was positive 2.
And this is negative 2.
So the final
magnification is minus 4.
So the answer to
the question is we
are going to have the
inverted real image
behind the second
lens, which is 30
millimeter behind
the second lens,
and which is 4 times larger
than the original object.
So if you have fewer
lens, like 2 or 3,
then this approach is pretty
straightforward, right?
We just consider one by one.
And just apply the
lens law, and you're
going to get the right answer.
OK.
So the previous
slide we just derived
the imaging condition,
which was the xo times xi
should be x squared or 1 over
s o plus 1 over si is 1 over f.
We just derived those equations
from the geometry, right?
We just compared
the few triangles
and get the final equations.
Well, I can do the same thing
with the ray matrix transform.
So let me do
[INAUDIBLE],, please.
So the way you do it, in
the ray transfer matrix,
you first define the angle
and height in object space
and image, right?
So here I have alpha
i and xi, which
is this angle and the height
of the image, h i actually.
And the input was xo and ho.
It's just this angle
and this height.
This ray is propagating
from left to right,
but I write the metrics
from right to left, right?
So first thing is the
propagation from here to here,
which is the distance by s o.
So the first matrix should
be 1 0, s 1, am I right?
Oh, as oh Yes so we just first
consider from here to here.
And then you have the
lens, which we just
derived last time, which was
1 negative 1 over f, 0 and 1.
And the next one is from here
to here, the same propagation.
So we have 1 0, si 1.
So this is the matrix
formulation in this case.
So if I compute
these matrices, then
actually I get this equation.
So let me write s o f si plus
s o minus si s o f 1 over f,
1 minus i over f ho.
So can you explain the imaging
condition from this matrix?
So we just derived the relation
between angle and height
in object, for the angle
and height in image.
And we have the
transfer matrix here.
So what's the imaging
condition in this case?
So let's go back to
the first [INAUDIBLE]..
So what is the image?
So we have a bunch of rays
starting from the object point.
And then all they arrive at the
same point in the image, right?
So if you just think about the h
i and ho here, so at that point
all these rays have
the same height, ho.
But they have different
alpha o, these guys, right?
But the image aside, the
same thing, all these rays
they have the same height, h i.
But they have a
different angle, alpha i.
So if you just compare
the h i and ho,
you know, those rays,
even though they
have different angles, but
they have the same height,
which means actually
this h i should
be independent from alpha 0.
Because no matter how
they depart at that point,
they have the same
height here, right?
So the answer is
actually this term,
because this is alpha i and h i.
So this term should be 0.
Because as I just
described, h i should
be independent on
alpha object, right?
So if I do the math,
then this is 1 over--
I just divide by s o and si.
So this one is 1 over s o
plus 1 over si minus 1 over f.
It should be 0, which
is, again, the lens law.
Yeah, so that's the
[INAUDIBLE] I described.
And if I plug in this
equation in this matrix,
finally I get these matrices So
if I continue at this occasion
then minus x over F1
of them zero minus x I
over f OK so the
upper right on is
we still have a
negative on about f
which is our last
power or optical power
and what is this
time the upper limit
Yeah this the last time
negative x I over f anyone
and there It's easy one.
Press the button, please.
AUDIENCE: Magnification?
SE BAEK OH: Yes.
Since this time is 0, so if
you think about the second row
here, then you have the
h i is just this guy
multiplied by ho, right?
So if you just think about
the second element here,
then h i is negative xi over f,
which is ho or object height.
So this time actually
tells you the relation
between the object
height and image height,
which is the magnification.
So I should say the
lateral magnification,
because we are talking
about the size.
So this term is magnification.
And it turns out that the
upper left term, this term, we
call the angular magnification.
Because there is related
with the alpha i and alpha o.
To be more precise, actually
angular magnification
is defined by the
ratio of change
in the image angle
and object angle.
And if you do the math, then
we finally get this term,
negative xo over f.
And it turns out that the
angular magnification is
1 over lateral magnification.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, what's the
idea of angular magnification?
We understand that lateral
magnification means
how much the object is scaled.
Yes.
But in the case of
imaging, what does it mean?
SE BAEK OH: That's
actually a good question.
So actually, if you see the
definition of the angular
magnification, it's actually
there is the delta, right?
So this delta alpha
change in image angle
over change in object
angle, which means let's
think about us those
rays here and here.
So you have the ray
angle in object space
and another ray in image space.
If you change this
angle in object space,
then you're going to also
change the angle in ray,
I mean in this side,
the image space.
So actually, angular
magnification
tells you how they are related.
So if you change this much, then
what do you get in this side?
How much change you
get in image space?
So I guess that's the
proper interpretation
of angular magnification.
It's the answer
to your question?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, thanks.
SE BAEK OH: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And does it
relate to numerical aperture
in some sense?
SE BAEK OH: Sure.
Actually, the
angular magnification
is xo over f, right?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
SE BAEK OH: Not really.
Yeah, it just depend on the--
you know, in this case
we don't have the notion
of the size of the lens here.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
SE BAEK OH: So it's not related.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, thanks.
SE BAEK OH: Any more question?
I'm supposed to go very slowly,
but there's no questions.
Then let's talk about the
next topic, so thick lens.
So, so far, we just think
about just thin lens.
All these were ray transfer
matrices or imaging condition.
We just consider the thin lens,
which has the two curvature.
But we didn't really account
for the thickness of the lens.
But if you think about the
real lens we've just seen,
the biconvex lens, actually
they have finite thickness,
like this.
So you have the first
surface and second surface,
but it has the finite thickness.
So what is the more
accurate or, I should say,
more rigorous way to model,
to make a model for this lens?
This answer is obvious, right?
So you just first take the
refraction at first surface
and just propagate the array
inside the glass, right?
And then take the
second refraction
at this second surface.
So that's, you know, the
proper way to describe.
So I can do the ray
transfer matrix here.
Yeah.
So we start with
the alpha 1 and x1,
which is the angle and height
in left side and alpha 2 and x2.
So it's alpha 2 and
x2 and alpha 1 and x1.
And the first matrix
should be the refraction
at this first surface.
So it should be one negative
left to right and R1 1 0.
By the way, is R1
positive or negative?
So R1 is the
curvature, radius of
curvature this first surface.
We talked about that last time.
If the center of the radius
curvature is that way, I mean,
which is the positive way,
then this radius curvature
is positive.
So actually R1 is positive.
And next matrix should be
propagation from first surface
to the second surface,
which is 1 0 d over n.
So don't forget n in
denominator, because it's not
[INAUDIBLE].
The ray is propagating
inside the glass.
And the last matrix should
be 1 and minus negative R
left to right and
radius curvature 1 0.
So these three matrices
describe this thick lens, right?
So we just consider the two
reflection and the propagation
through the glass.
And if I compute
these matrices, then I
get then actually M21 M22.
So I'll get the four different
elements, right, which is--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
SE BAEK OH: So actually if you
compute those three matrices,
I get this one.
But I just symbolize
M11, and M12, and--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
SE BAEK OH: Which one?
SE BAEK OH: d over n.
AUDIENCE: d over n.
SE BAEK OH: Yeah.
Because distance is d, but the
reflective [INAUDIBLE] is n.
So you need to divide by n.
Because, previously,
we had the thin lens,
which is just thin lens
like this and incoming ray.
They converge at
point like this.
And this was focal
length, right?
And the ray transfer
matrix for this thin lens
was 1 negative 1 over
f, 0 and 1, right?
So we get the--
yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
SE BAEK OH: Oh, where?
Oh.
[INAUDIBLE]
I'm sorry, yes.
All right, so it should be
n minus 1 and 1 minus n.
Yeah, it's confusing.
Actually, the way I remember
is the reflective index
at left side minus the
reflective index right side.
But there was negative
sign, so yeah.
I got [INAUDIBLE].
Yeah.
Thank you.
Sorry.
Yeah.
So what I was
going to talk about
is if we have the
thin lens, then
the ray transfer matrix it
was the 1 negative 1 over f
and 1 0.
But now, we have the thick lens.
That's why we have
complicated these four terms.
But we get the same
analogy of distance,
because distance
describe how much ray
bend, right, the optical
power or lens power.
So we get the same
thing here, which
is actually this
complicated term, this term.
And since it is a thick lens,
we define a new quantity which
is effective focal length.
So we consider that is a single
quantity which was negative 1
over effective focal length.
So effective focal
length is actually
the quantity inside the
bracket, so n minus 1 and 1
over R1 minus 1 over R2.
And we have extra term.
So what is this term, the n
minus 1 and 1 over R1 minus 1
over R2?
Yeah.
Actually, that's
what I described
at the very first slide, right?
So that's the lens
maker's equation.
So focal length of
thin lens and you
can compute the focal length
from the reflective index
and radius curvature, right?
But now we have
thick lens, so we
have extra term, this
function of the d,
the distance from the
first and second surface.
So if you consider a thick lens,
then the effective focal length
is not same as the
focal length, right?
So we just find the--
AUDIENCE: Where is the
focal length measured from?
Is it from the
middle of the lens?
SE BAEK OH: That's what I was
going to talk about, yeah.
AUDIENCE: OK.
SE BAEK OH: So we just find
the effective focal length
of the thick lens.
But, yeah, the exactly,
where the focus will be?
That's the next question, right?
Because we didn't
define any planes yet.
So let's think about it.
So first one is
back focal plane.
So we have an
object at infinity.
And so we have the ray
parallel to the optical axis.
And they bend twice,
here and here.
And finally, they want to
make our focus at here.
So this is focal plane.
And we can define the focal
length from this point, OK?
To find that point--
actually, this distance, right?
So actually, we
defined this distance
as back focal plane, so from
the second surface of the lens
to this back focal plane.
And then what I'm going
to do is find the distance
by ray transfer matrices.
So what I do is, so same
as before, alpha 2 and x2,
which is here.
But you know, the
x2 is 0, because it
is on the optical axis, right?
So it is actually 0.
And input is alpha 1 and x1,
this one, so this x1 and angle.
But since it is parallel to the
optical axis, the alpha 1 is 0.
And I just derived the
ray transfer matrix
of the thick lens, this guy.
I mean this whole guy.
So I have M11, M12, M21, M22.
And it's not the end, right?
So we have to propagate
again from here
to here by distance zb.
So it's going to be 1 0 zb 1.
So if you solve this
equation, then--
so this is just
what I've written.
So we have the 1 0, zb 1.
And this is our M matrices.
And if you solve this equation,
then we get two [INAUDIBLE],,
right?
We had the two equations.
So one is alpha 2 is negative
x1 and effective focal length.
So this sign means this
alpha 2 is heading downward.
So the amplitude means x1
over effective focal length.
And zb is actually
effective focal length
times 1 minus this guy.
So in this case,
actually the zb is
bigger than effective
focal length
or smaller than
effective focal length.
You know, in this case,
n is bigger than 1.
So this guy is positive.
So zb is actually smaller than
effective focal length, right?
Wake up, guys.
So we define this distance
zb as a back focal length.
And we just talk about the
effective focal length,
the quantity in the bracket.
And the 1 over
effective focal length
is power, the lens
power or optical power
of this thick lens.
So this distance is the
effective focal length.
This is the answer
to your question.
And we can do the same
thing in the other side.
So we start from the point.
We don't know where it is yet,
but the focal point in front
of the lens, which is the front
focal plane, front focal point.
And they bend twice.
And finally, they
get collimated,
because it's going to
the image at infinity.
So the ray matrices, in this
case, are alpha 2 and x2
and alpha 1 and x1.
But now, we start from the
point on the optical axis.
So x1 should be 0.
And at the end, we are going
to have the x2, but alpha 2
equals 0.
So this should be 0.
And first matrices
we should consider
is this propagation
by the zf, right?
So it's going to be 1 0 zf 1.
And then we have the thick
lens, so M11, M12, M21, M22.
And if you solve this
equation, then we also
get the 2 [INAUDIBLE],, which is
the front focal length, which
is zf from here to here.
And this is what you get.
And the second in x2 is alpha
1 times effective focal length.
Question?
I guess it's time to break.
Yeah.
Let's take a break here.
So next time, I'm
going to continue
to explain these front focal
length and back focal length
and how they are related.
And meantime, we had
the demo set up here.
So you're welcome
to come and see.
And what we have here is
actually the imaging set up.
We have a single
lens here and object,
which is the resolution target.
And we have the screen here.
So if you move this
screen back and forth
or lens and the image--
we cannot move the object.
So basically we're going
to demonstrate the imaging
condition.
So if the distance
is properly located,
then we are going to
see the very nice image.
But if not, then the
image looks blurry.
GUEST SPEAKER: So before we
continue with all the math,
some of you came
to see the demo.
And for the ones
that didn't come,
I suggest you to
come after class.
It's easier to see the
image we try to form,
because we don't have
the dynamic range
problem that any camera has.
But anyways, the main
idea of this demo
is to show what we've
been learning about,
an imaging of a
single lens, right?
So if you can
summarize this points
so far what we've learned,
we've learned the thin lenses,
thick lenses, right?
So it's just a
refractive element
that is capable of forming
an image from a given point,
either at infinity or a close
distance, to another plane.
That's what we learned.
Another important point
that we've learned today
is the imaging condition, right?
Imaging condition
is just depending
on three variables, the
distance from the lens
to the image plane,
si, the distance
from the lens to
the object plane,
s o, and the focal
length, right?
This is one of the
most important things.
Because basically
this tells you,
if I want to have an in-focus
very sharp, nice image,
I can either play with two of
variables, keep one constant.
So for example, in these
demo what I'm going to show
you is how a single
lens, a positive lens,
performs imaging of
a thin transparency.
So in this case,
I'm going to start
showing here how I'm
illuminating this transparency,
which is here.
It's just a piece of glass
that has some dark coded
lines of different sizes.
It's called a resolution target.
And we're illuminating these
with white light from the back.
So it's just like transparency
for an overhead projector
you can think of.
Then this is a
positive lens here
that will basically form
an image at another screen
here, right?
So now, let's look at
these quantities physically
that we've learned
in the math here.
This distance from here to
here is the object distance.
That's the s o
from the equation.
This lens has a fixed focal
length, which I cannot change.
It's just a piece of glass
curved in a given way.
So this distance here is the
distance to the image plane.
So these two distances
I really can change, A,
to get a sharp focus to make
sure that my image is exactly
on my screen, and/or if I want
to play with a magnification.
Because remember
from the math, if you
can see the notes before,
that the lateral magnification
depends on the ratio
of minus si, which
is these distance, over s o,
which is this distance, right?
So let's lower the
exposure here just
to see the image that
we have here, please.
All right, so we lowered
the exposure again
for the same reasons
of dynamic range.
So I'm going to try to
focus here on the image.
So this is the image that we
are forming on the screen.
And as you can see, so there
is a bunch of lines, stripes,
and squares with numbers.
And it's very sharply in focus.
So now what I'm going
to do, and hopefully we
can see it with a
camera, is that I'm
going to change the ratio
between these two distances.
So what if, for example, I
want to demagnify my image?
So the magnification quantities
I use describe si over s o.
Forget about the minus sign.
The minus sign just tells you
that it's an inverted image.
si over s o, I want
that quantity smaller.
What should I do?
I'm going to repeat the
question one more time.
Magnification equal to 1,
I want magnification, say,
less than 1.
How can I reduce that M number?
M equals minus si over s o.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GUEST SPEAKER: What?
GUEST SPEAKER: OK.
Just push the button and
repeat what you just said.
AUDIENCE: Increase
the distance s o,
so you move it
closer to the screen.
GUEST SPEAKER: So if I move
the lens closer to the screen,
effectively I reduce si,
the imaging distance.
So let's try it.
So I'm going to move these
lens closer to this side.
So s o increases, of course.
And I can just look at the
right position here for focus.
So now, this
distance is smaller.
And it's hard to
see with a webcam,
but the image is still in focus.
It's smaller, demagnified
respect to the one
that I showed you before.
But yeah, that basically
will accomplish this, right?
So for this part, if
you can come and play
with these distances
later after class,
you will see how this
relationship works, right?
So in this case, we have these
two variables, the s o and si
that we're playing at.
But as we'll see in a
second, for the eye,
it's a very different story.
Because in the eye, the lens
of the eye and the retina,
so in this case would
be your si, is fixed.
You cannot change it.
It's the shape of your eye.
So how can the eye focus
far distance objects
or when you read nearby objects?
So it has to do
similar tricks playing
in the imaging conditions,
such that it always
has a sharp image.
The way the eye does it, and
we'll see it in a second,
is by changing the focal length.
So now, the two variables
become f and s o.
And you can do the same trick.
So this was a positive lens.
We will learn about
negative power lenses,
so the ones are curved
like this, right?
So in these ones, we've
learned that these
generate these weird
non-intuitive virtual images,
right?
So I was just
asking the students
that came here,
what did they expect
to see if I put this lens here?
Anyone wants to guess other
than the students that
already answered the question?
What do you think will--
let me put it in this way.
Would I see an image and where?
Or should I not see anything
if I put this negative lens?
Image or no image?
Singapore?
AUDIENCE: Unless you form
the image with another lens,
you don't see it.
GUEST SPEAKER: OK, let's try it.
I put the negative lens.
Actually, I'm going
to put it in this.
Oh.
We lost the video.
Give me just one second.
All right, so I put
the negative lens.
Let me move it back and forth.
And yeah, you can see here
I have just a bright patch
of light, no image, right?
So you said that, if
we use another lens,
we can make that image
into a real image.
What type of lens do you think
we need to add and where?
OK, I'll answer that one.
OK.
You can answer?
AUDIENCE: A positive lens
after the negative lens,
before the screen?
GUEST SPEAKER: Exactly.
So essentially, physically
what this is doing
is that the light going
out from the object
gets even bent
outwards more, right?
So it basically essentially
forms a virtual object
behind the lens, right?
So the positive lens,
what it's going to do
is grab these outward rays and
focus them back into the screen
to form an image.
And let's just try it.
Now, I have the two lenses.
Just make sure that
the exposure is--
We're reducing the exposure.
Oh, it's hard to see here, but
there's lines again, right?
So then we have an image.
So essentially, as I
was mentioning before,
this is what our
eye would do for us
when we see virtual images.
We have a visual
image, and our eye
is the lens that
focuses this light
and converts this virtual
image into a real image, right?
We'll understand more how
the eye works in a second.
So I think we're going to switch
back to the normal class mode.
Thanks for the presentation.
SE BAEK OH: OK, so we were
talking about the thick lens.
So by using ray
transfer matrices,
we just derived the effective
focal length of a thick lens.
And we defined the back focal
plane, back focal length,
and the front focal
length, which is function
of effective focal length.
And let's see how
they are related.
So first one we have
the infinite conjugate
configuration.
So we have an
object at infinity.
And at back focal
plane, we have focus.
And we just derived
the two equations,
which is alpha 2 is x1 over
effective focal length.
And that focal length is
effective focal length
times some extra factor.
And what I'm going
to do here is I just
measure the effective
focal length
from the back focal plane.
And since the back
focal length it
means the focal plane
to the second surface
is shorter than the
effective focal length,
so actually in this
case we are going
to have the plane, the virtual
plane, inside of the glass.
And from that equation, which
is alpha 2 and alpha 2 equal x1
over effective focal
length, it turns out
that if you extend this ray
over here and this ray over here
they actually meet
at that plane.
So it's essentially
you can think,
even though you have thick lens,
but you have thin lens there.
So ray just-- propagating from
straight and at this plane
and bend and make a focus there.
So we call this plane a
second principal plane,
because it's associated
with a back focal plane.
So it is a second
principal plane.
And you can do the same thing
in the other side, of course.
So we had different focal plane.
And I measure from here to
here by effective focal length.
And effective focal
length is actually
longer than the front focal
plane, zf, from here to there.
So it's still inside the glass.
And if you extend
out those rays,
actually they meet
at this plane.
So we call this first
principal plane.
So I just put these
two figures together.
So I have thick lens.
And we have different
focal point.
And this distance [INAUDIBLE]
the surface of the lens
is front focal length.
And we defined the
same thing here.
So we have the back focal point.
And we defined the back focal
length from here to here.
And from the ray
transfer matrix,
we defined the effective focal
length of this thick lens.
So we defined the
first principal plane
and second principal plane.
And that's the
effective focal length.
And so conceptually, these
thick lens can be assumed.
We already computed ray
transfer matrices, right?
So we can conceptually
think we have the thin lens,
but it's the first surface
in a infinite thin lens.
The first surface
and second surface
is actually the
first principal plane
and the second principal plane.
And if you remember the infinite
conjugate configuration,
if ray from the
object at infinity,
so it's propagating parallel
to the optical axis,
then it bends at the
second principal plane
and make focus at
back focal plane.
And same thing here
if you have the point
object at the
different focal plane.
And it bends at the
first principal plane,
and collinate it, and
goes to the infinity.
So actually reason
why we introduced
this concept, the
principal plane
and effective focal length
is actually pretty simple.
Because we start with
the thin lens, but now
we had the thick lens.
So what if we have multiple
lenses, like thick lenses?
So no matter how complicated
the optical system is,
we can always find the
effective focal length
and this first and
second principal plane.
So once we have this first
and the second principal plane
and effective focal
length, f here, then we
can treat this whole
system as one thin lens.
So for example-- come on.
So we have the object
in object space.
And ray, it's exactly
the same as a thin lens.
We choose two rays, right?
So the first one is bent at
the second principal plane.
And it's passed through
the back focal plane--
back focal point, sorry.
And the second ray goes
through the front focal point
and it bend at the
first principal plane.
And it's collimated.
And they meet at some point.
So you can easily find the
image even though your system
is pretty complicated.
But once you find
these two principal
plane and effective
focal length,
then you can still use the
same equation as a thin lens.
Come on.
Yeah, all these equations.
So you can define the
same thing, xo and s
o, the image distance and
object distance like this.
And you can use
the same equation,
so Newton's form, xo times
xi equals to f squared.
And the lens law, 1 over
object distance plus 1
over image distance,
should be 1 over f.
So f is effective focal
length in this case.
And the lateral magnification
and angular magnification,
they're defined the same way.
And I just want to
mention that the-- yes?
AUDIENCE: Where is
[INAUDIBLE] on that picture?
Because the effective focal
length you talked about depends
on the [INAUDIBLE] between
the first [INAUDIBLE]..
SE BAEK OH: So actually,
the effective focal length
depend on the stuff inside
of the neuro-optical system.
So the thick lens
we just consider
one thick lens-- so
one, the first surface,
and lens, and second surface.
But I'm going to actually
talk about that later.
But what if we have two lens?
So we first consider
first lens and propagation
and the second lens.
So you can define the effective
focal length the same way, OK?
So in this case, the
effective focal length
is not related to the
aperture or whatever.
It just depend on the
reflective index and distance
between the optical element.
AUDIENCE: But in the
effective focal length
you've got the parameter
b, [INAUDIBLE]..
SE BAEK OH: Yeah, distance
between the elements, right?
AUDIENCE: OK, so that's
width of the lens?
SE BAEK OH: Yes.
AUDIENCE: So--
SE BAEK OH: Yeah?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Over here we have
this duality between x object
and x image, but
we always have 1f.
Is that only because
we're assuming
that the lens has the
same radius of curvature
on either side for now?
SE BAEK OH: No, no.
AUDIENCE: Or is
it always just 1f?
SE BAEK OH: No, no.
So effective focal length
is just function of--
yeah, maybe it's
confusing, but the--
so in this thick lens,
the effective focal length
is just function of the radius
curvature and reflective index
and d, right?
So the concept of this
effective focal length
and principal plane, we
treat the whole system
as one thing lens.
And one thing lens has the
same focal length in front side
and rear side, right?
So effective focal
length is already
same in front side and
the back side of the lens.
But it depends on the system.
Because right now, I just
talk about this thick lens.
So that's why we have only,
1, 2, 3, 4 parameter here.
But if I have another thick
lens as [INAUDIBLE] here,
then effective focal length
is more complicated, right?
So it's also a function of the
reflective index, and distance,
and the curvature of
the second lens, OK?
Now, we'll talk about--
I mean, actually I'll
show you [INAUDIBLE]..
AUDIENCE: So for
one lens, you always
have one effective focal
length to characterize
the entire lens?
SE BAEK OH: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: No matter
what the sides are?
SE BAEK OH: Yeah.
So let's say if you
have the 100 length.
But you can always find the
one effective focal length.
Yeah.
So actually, if you have
a digital camera, then
typically you have multiple
lens, or three or four or five.
But you only have the
one focal length in it.
I mean, they only specify
one focal length, right?
So that is actually
effective focal length.
So they already compute
this whole thing, OK?
So that's the reason why
we introduced this concept.
And I just want to mention
the center ray which
is starting from
the object point,
but is incident on the center
at the first principal plane.
And if you remind the thin lens
case, then at the thin lens
that ray actually just pass
through the center of the ray,
right?
So the same here, so that
ray is starting again
at the second principal
plane, at the center
of the second principal plane.
And it goes to the image.
And of course, if you
have the same medium
in front of the principal plane
and behind the principal plane,
then this angle and this
angle are same, right?
Because you know,
at the center you
will just have a piece of glass.
So by the [INAUDIBLE] law,
they should be parallel.
OK, actually, that's about it.
So the take home
message is we just talk
about the imaging condition.
Anyway, by the way,
he's going to talk
about the human visual system.
So take home message
of my part is we
just talk about
imaging condition,
which is 1 over s o and
plus 1 over si is 1 over f.
And there are some
mathematical way
to find or to write the
condition, OK, which
is the ray transfer matrices.
And we just introduced the
front focal length and back
focal length and
principal planes.
But I didn't really
talk about how
to find this principal
place OK so let
me finish we are hard to find
the principal place if you have
multiple elements which he was
the of course we have the two
example of two lenses
so that completes
so initially we
had the example that two
lens which has focal length
is 10, 10.
And distance is 5 millimeter.
And the object was
also 5 [INAUDIBLE]..
By the way, Professor
Barbastathis,
he posted a different way to do
it, to find where the image is,
or how big it is, and where
is the principal plane,
and what's the effective length.
He summarized all
these different method,
and he posted on a
[INAUDIBLE] website
in a supplement material.
So please go to the
website and review it.
And it looks complicated.
But once [INAUDIBLE],, then
it's pretty straightforward.
And you will never forget.
You're not going to forget.
So please do it.
I strongly suggest you.
So let's continue how to find
the principal planes here.
So there are a bunch
of different ways.
So I'm going to do the
first one the easy way.
So let's first find the
back focal plane first,
because we know.
The definition of
the focal plane,
if you remind the thin
lens, like this, then
these incoming rays, they
converged at one point, right?
So in this case,
let's first assume
I have the ray coming
from infinity like this.
And I do the cascade method.
So I just consider
first lens here.
And where is my image?
Actually, we already computed,
like, it's already computed.
So this focal length is distance
10, right, so distance f.
So by the first lens, I
draw only one ray here.
This is parallel to
the optical axis.
So third ray actually
goes to the focal point
of the first lens,
which is 10, right?
But we do have the
second lens here.
So if you do the lens equation,
then actually it bends more.
So finally, what you get is
it coming in, bend like this.
It's supposed to go like this,
but it bend more like this.
So this point is back focal
point of these two lens system.
And if you do the same thing, so
you extend the [INAUDIBLE] ray
like this, and if you
extend like this, then where
they meet, actually
that's the position
of the second principal plane.
Because you have
all the numbers,
you can easily find the
position of this guy.
And so this distance is actually
the effective focal length.
And the distance from the second
lens to the back focal point
is actually back focal length.
So we just find the second
principal plane here,
second principal plane.
And you can do the same
thing in object side.
You start with the point
source on optical axis.
And at the end, you're going
to get the collimated light.
So since it is symmetric,
so it's actually
you're going to put the ray
like this and bend like this.
And it's finally collimated.
So if you do the same
thing, then you're
going to get the first
principal plane here.
And this is effective
focal length,
which is same as before.
And you can find the front
focal plane, front focal length.
So that's the just
conceptual way
to find the principal plane
and effective focal length.
But if you want to be
accurate or precise,
then you can always use
the ray transfer matrix.
So let me do this.
We have two lens,
focal length f.
So let's start with
actually this interface
at the end of the second lens.
So we have here alpha o and
xo and here alpha i and xi.
So I have alpha i
xi, alpha o and xo.
And I assume this
lenses are thin lenses.
So first matrices should
be 1 over 1 and negative 1
over f and 0 1.
And next one is the
propagation from here to here.
So this should be 1 0.
Actually, this is 4 1, because--
that's 5, 5.
And the second lens, it should
be same as the first one, 1, 1
over negative f 0 1.
So if you could
compute this one,
then you are going to get this
is 1 minus 1 0 and 1 0, 5 1,
and 1 minus 1 10, 1 0, 0.
And you're getting, it should
be, 1 over 2 negative 3 over 20
and 5 1 over 2 and alpha
object and x object.
So I should remind the thin
lens case, which is 1 minus 1
over f 0 1.
So actually this guy is 1
over effective focal length.
So in this case, effective focal
length should be 20 over 3.
So this is how to find
the effective focal length
by using ray transfer matrices.
And you can find the back focal
length and front focal length.
Just cascade
another propagation,
you know, just like
what we did in class.
So here and here, you can find
the back focal plane, back
focal plane, and front focal
plane, and front focal length,
and, you know, first and
second principal plane.
So since Professor posted
the detailed material,
he actually derived
four different rays.
So please visit the website
and do it by yourself.
Thank you.
GUEST SPEAKER: OK.
So, so far, we've been
learning about lenses
and some sort of imaging
techniques and principles.
But more than
that, we've learned
about some optical
principles that
regulate how light propagates,
namely refraction, reflection
so far, total
internal reflection.
So now the question is,
how does nature does it?
And how has it evolved over the
past several, several years?
And it actually
comes down, according
to these reference
here, to eight
different possible
configurations of eyes.
And just by the
way, defining an eye
is more complicated than
just a simple photoreceptor.
So an eye, it's
a little bit more
evolved like some sort of
forming either an image
or a shadow based system.
So these type of eyes can be
broadly categorized or divided
into chamber eyes, the ones
that I'm showing here, OK?
So let's look at these eyes here
and see what principles apply
from what we've learned so far.
So in C and in D,
we can see what?
Snell's law, right?
So this is refraction.
So these type of eyes,
again, like our human eye,
focus the light
and form an image
in some sort of photoreceptors
located here, right?
Then we have also
reflection based.
These lenses here--
I'm sorry, this
mirror base here where
the light gets reflected
and forms an image
in a photoreceptor here.
And now, we also have another
one that is an aperture based,
or you can think of these has
been as a natural pin hole.
And these images form
by shadows, right?
So you see the
shadow difference.
So these are the four
types of chamber eyes.
But even more
older type of eyes,
we have the compound eye, as we
said in the very first lecture.
They're made out of a segmented
array of many apertures
or many elements.
You can think about
like many lenses
for the case of our
refractive based system.
Or for our reflective
based system,
it's several apertures that
reflect the light somewhere
here and also focus it into
some photoreceptive sensor.
Or in this case,
for instance, here,
each one of these segments
sees a very tiny field of view
and integrates all that field
of view into that photoreceptor.
So in reality, it's not
like the type of images
that we're used to, right?
It's just sort of
like a blurry version
of our images in this case.
But of course, of very
important interest to us
is how the human eye works.
Because as we know, we've
experienced-- we have eyes--
it's an extremely robust and
very elaborate optical system.
I just said one of the problems
we've had with the demo
is the adaptive
to dynamic range.
Our eyes can do that very well.
We can also go to
read a book or just
look at something far away.
And we can focus pretty
well, too, right?
So all these things and
all these adaptations
regulate these optical
principles that we presented
are actually what made
a lot of researchers
to try to study the eye and
how the eye perceives light.
So that's under the field
of visual perception.
So this is the
structure of the eye.
The eye, it's
essentially a sphere.
And it's all covered
by some white opaque
layer called the sclera.
And that basically blocks
straight light going through.
The only transparent section
of the eye is the cornea, here.
So in the cornea, the
light can go through.
And the cornea is the first
refractive element of the eye.
It's curved.
It has a refractive index
of something like 1.37,
which basically is the
largest bending of light.
Because it comes from
air to this 1.37 element.
So that's why you can think
of that when you are actually
swimming it's hard to see.
Why?
Because the index of
refraction of water
is 1.33, very close
to that of the cornea.
So then the bending of light
that occurs in this first layer
is very minimal.
So after the cornea,
we have some chamber
filled with a solution called
aqueous humor, which basically
nourishes the eye, especially
the cornea, keeps it alive.
That is very similar to water.
Now, we have then the iris.
The iris is the element
that controls-- well,
it's functional purpose is to
control the amount of light
that your eye receives.
So as we know, the iris
expands and contracts
depending on the amount of light
present in the environment.
And actually, it's
very impressive.
It can go from, like, 2
millimeters in diameter
to 8 millimeters in
diameter depending
on the light condition.
But it's also responsible for
the nice color of the eyes
that we see, like blue
eyes, green eyes, you know?
That's the one to blame.
The aperture or the hole that we
have is what we call the pupil.
So after the iris, we have
the second most-- yeah?
AUDIENCE: Does the color
of the eye [INAUDIBLE]??
GUEST SPEAKER: No.
It's due to-- and actually
it's very interesting.
So no, it basically
just blocks the light.
It acts like an aperture, like
of the aperture of your camera.
So if you like, photography
would control the speed
or the f number of your system.
But the light
reflected from the eye
gets the color in
a similar principle
to why the sky is blue.
And I'll just let you
investigate, because actually
it's very interesting.
And we used to have that
problem in the first p set.
Why the sky is blue?
Why clouds are white?
And I guess the physical
phenomena of why that happens
is very interesting.
So you guys should read.
It's in Hecht.
OK, so after the
iris, we have these
what is called the crystalline
lens, this lens here.
This is the second optical
component most important
in our eye.
It's basically multilayer
fibrous mass element covered
by some elastic membrane.
It's transparent.
And it can contract and
deform itself in such a way
that it changes the effective
focal length of this lens.
But you can think
about this element
as some transparent quasi-onion.
But in addition, it has
very interesting properties.
Because these lens is actually
a gradient refractive index
lens, is, what we learned in
some classes, a green lens,
this element here.
It has a refractive index in
the core something like 1.4.
And it decays all the way
to something like 1.38
to the edges.
So the light gets basically--
see the transition.
So this is similar
to the p set one.
And it basically
sees multiple layers.
So depending indices
of refraction,
it starts bending accordingly.
OK, so this lens will, in
conjunction with this cornea,
form what we call
or we could model
this system as a dual or
double lens optical system.
And combined, they
have an optical power--
and remember the
optical power is
1 over the focal length, which
it's measure in diopters--
of equivalent of something
like 59 diopters,
just so you get an idea
for an unaccommodated eye
or a relaxed eye just
looking at infinity.
So then after this lens,
we have another chamber
with another fluid
called vitreous humor.
And it's another fluid that
basically gives support
to the eye.
And going back to our question,
I think someone in Singapore
had in the very first
lecture, this fluid
has a lot of little
particles floating, debris.
And actually sometimes
you can see them.
And maybe many of
you have seen them.
If you see to the sky
or you squint your eyes
and see a bright
light source, you
see the shadows of these little
particles that are freely
flowing in the vitreous humor.
And you can see the fringes
if you look carefully
of the light refracting that.
OK, so after that,
the light basically
gets focused into the retina.
We know the retina is
composed of photoreceptors,
photoreceptive
cells, cone and rods.
And I'm going to explain
those in a couple of slides.
And then we can also
identify two other points.
We identify here that
each of these cells
are connected to optical nerves.
And they all basically
come together
into this output that
goes to the brain.
And this is what
constitutes the blind spot.
And I also explained that.
And we have a fun
exercise in a second.
And we also have
this other region,
which is like a spot of 3
millimeters in diameter,
more or less.
It's like a yellow spot.
It's called the macula.
And it has the largest
concentration of cones.
And I'll explain what is its
role, but it is very important.
Just that section here
accounts for 90% to 95%
of our visual perception.
So I talked about the ability
of these crystalline lens
to accommodate, change
the focal length.
And similar to this demo
that we were changing
the distance between these
guys, well, in this case,
as I said before, this
isn't fixed, right,
unless you have some sort
of disease that actually
changes the length of your eye.
And that actually happens.
We can think of as this fixed.
So if we want to focus
objects other than infinity,
we need to play now with
a focal length, right?
So now, this lens has to
be capable of changing
the effective focal
length in such a way
that it will
conserve or preserve
the imaging distance here.
So here, this lens does it
by contracting or expanding
the ciliary muscles
that are connected
via some fibers to
these lens, right?
So in a relaxed state,
you see this case here.
The radius of curvature of
this lens, it's very large,
like closer to infinity,
say, like very flat.
And then it focuses
nice into the retina,
like a plane wave, whereas,
for nearby objects,
these muscles are stressed.
So then the radius of
curvature of the lens changes.
The focal length changes.
Now, this image is focusing
to, again, the retina.
So we can think about some
of the conditions that
would affect the normal
behavior of the lens of the eye.
And the two very important
conditions that we have
is farsighted or nearsighted.
So in the farsighted
case, for example, our eye
lost its ability to
focus effectively.
And in a relaxed state, it will
actually form a focal point.
So the back focal point, it will
be far away behind our retina.
So actually what you see
would be a blurry image.
In their myopia
case, or nearsighted,
you see the opposite.
Now, the point is formed
in front of the retina.
And again, you see
a blurry signal.
And by the way, a far point
for a normal healthy eye
it starts from something
like 5 meters on.
So 5 meters, more or less,
what you can see there
is still like a five point.
So for someone that
suffers myopia, typically
they see close by
objects pretty fine.
But far objects,
let's say further than
the far point, something
like 5 meters away,
they become blurry.
And the near point, which is the
counterpart of the far point,
is how close can we see.
That's a point that
also varies with age.
Normally, teenagers
the closer they can see
is something like 7 centimeters.
For us, maybe it's
around 10 to 12--
you can try later by
just trying to focus
your notebook, centimeters.
And then if you are
over 60 years old,
it goes up to 100 centimeters.
So basically, you
can see how the eye
starts decaying in
its ability to modify
this crystalline lens.
So to correct for
these conditions,
we can use what we've
learned so far, positive
and negative lenses, right?
So let's think about it.
In this case, the rays
are not focusing enough,
are not bending enough, right?
Because they are basically
focusing behind that.
So I want to help the rays
to focus a little bit more.
So a positive power lens or a
positive lens, like this one,
allows me to bend the
rays inward more, right?
And this essentially
what this is happening.
The positive power bends these
parallel rays more and then
assures that this
focuses in the retina.
So let me ask a question.
What do you think happens
with the magnification
for this case?
Any idea?
For those of you
that wear glasses,
do you guys see the
world larger, magnified?
No?
There is shaking head, no.
Why do you think
it's not the case?
OK-- so the power of
the optical system,
the compound optical system.
So if you work out actually
the power of the cornea
plus crystalline
lens-- which I said
is something like 59
for a healthy eye.
But in reality when it's
unhealthy, it changes.
And if you consider the power
added by this element here,
it basically comes down to the
same power as the healthy eye.
So therefore, you don't
add or subtract any power.
So therefore, the
magnification stays the same.
For the myopia case, we
can use the opposite.
We can use a negative
lens, as shown here,
to actually bend the rays a
little bit outwards, right?
So essentially
this is interesting
because, again the myopia case
you cannot you see far away
objects blurry right but
some objects are closer than
the fire point you can see them
fine so what the negative lens
is doing--
and again, going back to
these virtual images--
is bringing a far away object
into a near distance closer
to the far point.
As you can see, this appears
to come from some virtual point
here that is closer
from a region
that you can see
naturally with your eye.
So therefore,
intuitively this is
how this ray makes
this lens still project
the image into the retina.
But as a side effect,
the near point-- yup?
AUDIENCE: So can
people [INAUDIBLE]
focal point closer
than [INAUDIBLE]??
GUEST SPEAKER: No.
And actually, yeah, that
was the second point
I was going to say.
As a consequence of
this, your near point,
which I said that for
like a healthy eye
would be something like 12
centimeters, becomes larger.
So people that have myopia--
I don't know if
there's anyone here.
But probably you
know that sometimes,
if you want to read a
very close by document,
you need to remove
your glasses, right?
And people adjust
OK for small print.
They get out their glasses.
And for far away objects, they
put their glasses on and see.
All right, so any
other questions?
OK, so the retina,
the retina has a bunch
of cells that are
photoreceptive cells that
can be classified into two
types, rods and cones, right?
And we can see here
rods and cones.
For those of you that
like photography,
you can think about the
rods being equivalent
of a high speed
black and white film.
What is the meaning of that?
It basically means that is very,
very sensitive to light, OK?
For very low levels of light,
you can detect them very fine.
But it's insensitive
to color and gives you
images that are not
really good quality,
sort of like blurry
type of images, right?
The cones, on the
other hand, can
be thought of as low contrast
or low speed color film.
So the cones have cells that are
sensitive to red, green, blue,
are responsible for
the colors that we see
and are also responsible
of the nice, sharp images.
So all around the
retina, we have
sort of a combination of both.
Although as you can see here
in the density plot shown here,
there is a region that
is called the macula.
And inside the macula, there
is even a smaller region
of something like 300 micron.
That's called the fovea.
That has the highest
concentration of cones, again,
those responsible for the
color vision-- as you can see,
the plot just peaks here--
and almost no rods, right?
This is called the
fovea centralis.
And that's responsible
of the central vision.
And basically,
that's the one that I
was saying that's
responsible for 90% to 95%
of the visual
perception that we have.
So it's interesting
to note that,
in contrast to a normal
camera, there sampling of these
photoreceptor elements-- so
you can think of it as, like,
pixels--
it's different.
Outside the macula, they
are large and course.
As you can see,
these rods are just
responsible for the peripheral
vision and black and white.
But in this macula, they are
very concentrated and dense.
And as a matter of fact, the
cones inside this region,
so when they are here, they
have a different diameter
than the ones outside.
There is something
like a factor of two
that are actually thinner.
So they are very
close packed together.
So you can see very
sharp images here.
As I mentioned before, each
of these photoreceptors
is connected to
these nerves that all
bundle up together and go to
the blindspot, shown here.
Now, have you guys been bothered
by a blind spot all your lives?
Not really.
Why?
Because as you can
see, it's actually
just blocking a very small
portion of your vision.
As I said, a lot of the
vision or visual perception
happens in this region, right?
This is not true if
you have a camera.
If I have a camera and we have
a bunch of bad pixels like that,
it might corrupt our system.
And then we're done.
Like, if a microscope
experiment, for example,
forget about it.
We lose a lot of pixels,
and then the image
gets really corrupted.
So I brought a little card.
I'm going to pass it around.
I have actually
multiple of these.
So this is a fun experiment.
It has, in the top
part, a little cross
and a little black circle.
In the bottom
part-- another cross
and a line that is
basically truncated, right?
So what you're going
to do when you get
it is that you're going to have
the cross to your right side.
And you're going to
close your right eye.
And then you're going to
just play with this distance
staring at the cross.
So you're going to focus
your left eye at the cross.
And you're going to
find a position here
in which the circle
will disappear, right?
Because the circle
essentially will
be imaged into this blind spot,
and we're not going to see it.
But the second one
is more interesting.
Because you do the same thing,
and the hole here disappears.
But not only disappears,
it gets filled with a line.
So you'll see a continuous line.
And it's more shocking,
because basically our brain
fills that missing information.
It's actually
pretty interesting.
So I don't know if you can
help me pass this around.
How do I go to the next one?
[INAUDIBLE] this one?
OK, takes forever.
OK.
So this is a simulation that it
was done by a group in Caltech.
They were trying
to simulate what
would be the image
that our eye actually
is projecting at the retina.
What is exactly what we see?
And interestingly
enough, compared
to a normal image of the same
scene produced by a CCD camera,
as you can see, the
image is really blurry
in the surroundings,
very sharp in the center,
as we described due to
the sampling, et cetera.
So the eye tries to take
advantage of the fact
that it has a very small,
very sharp region in focus
as much as it can.
And the way it does it
is by jittering the eye,
moving it at a frequency of
something like 30 to 70 Hertz,
to scan a given scene and try
to collect as much information
to create the scene that
we perceive in our brain.
And also, there is
some interesting image
processing to try to
account for this blurring.
Or you can think of
that, for those of you
that are in signal processing,
deep learning algorithms
embedded in our brains.
I think it's pretty interesting.
So the phenomena of
moving of the eye,
it's called saccadic motion.
Also, the cones and
the rods, as I said,
are connected with nerves.
But it was first proposed
by studying the eye of a cat
and then for humans
that the eye actually
has this type of responds
to a light as stimulus,
that in some regions it's
going to be positive.
Some regions it's going to
be negative following what
is called a Mexican-hat trend.
And actually, this
response is what
is responsible for
many optical illusions
that we see, for
example, this one.
So what do you guys see?
You've seen this one
probably before, no?
So you see this
flickering gray dots
that are really not there right
and if you try to focus your
eye and if you are like as close
as I am to the projector
and I'm focusing my eye
here I don't see anything of the
at least at that point I don't
see any great does however if
I focus in another point right
I'm also seeing this flicker.